DIRE STATE:
This man has 1.2 billion subscribers.
What channel does he run? Well, he runs our
favorite channels 5 Minute Crafts, 123 Go!,
Bright Side, Slick Slime Sam, La La Life, and Baby
Zoo just to name a few. All of these channels are
owned by a corporation called The Soul Publishing
which is run by our protagonist Pavel Radaev.
The company was only founded 7 years ago, but
given that they post hundreds of videos per day
across 21 languages, they’ve essentially been
able to brute force their way to the top. But
while things look good on the surface, underneath
the hood, things aren’t going that great. In fact,
they’re looking pretty bad. Take 5 minute crafts
for example. The channel has a whopping 80 million
subscribers but a lot of their videos can’t even
break 100k view. It’s even worse at Bright Side.
A total of 45 million subscribers but many videos
can’t even break 20k views. Zooming out a bit,
Bright Side used to pull in 150 to 200 million
views per month back in their hayday but now
the channel is down to 40 to 50 million views
per month. Not a bad amount but given that they
post 3 times a day, it’s very possible that this
operation is now unprofitable. A similar story can
be seen with their subscriber count as well. Since
last October, Bright Side has had multiple months
where their net subscriber gain was straight up
0. Clearly things aren’t looking great from a
business perspective but there’s more to it than
just that. You see, it’s easy to dismiss the Soul
Publishing as just some soulless content farm
that’s looking to milk social media for views.
But, when you take a deeper look, a much darker
agenda becomes more evident. Their quirky content
is actually laced with politics and pro Russian
versions of history. One of their now deleted
videos for example, claimed that Ukraine is part
of Russia back in 2019. Another claimed that
Alaska was a gift to the US from the Soviet Union.
And when you consider that the company is run by
a bunch of Russian nationals, this all starts to
make sense. This means that the Soul Publishing
may not just be the world’s largest content
farm but also the world’s largest propaganda
machine. So, here’s the controversial rise and
fall of the biggest YouTube empire of all time.
SHADY BEGINNINGS?:
Taking a look back, the story of the Soul
Publishing indeed only dates back to 2016,
but the story of the company behind the company,
AdMe, dates back to the early 2000s to two men
named Pavel Radaev and Marat Mukhametov. AdMe
started off as a media platform that seeked to
offer serious informational content. But, over
time this evolved into being more light hearted
content focused on entertainment as this simply
appealed to a far larger audience. They basically
became the Russian BuzzFeed and would eventually
transition this style over to their dozens of
YouTube channels which brings us into our first
controversy: the timeline of the Soul Publishing.
After being a Russian focused media
organization for over a decade,
AdMe decided to launch the Soul Publishing in
2016. This has prompted some to theorize that
the Soul Publishing was created to influence
the 2016 election. At one point even Forbes
and Business Insider explored the idea but these
claims don’t hold up against further scrutiny.
For starters, many of the Soul Publishing’s most
popular channels were actually created after the
election. 5 Minute Crafts for example was created
a week after the election and Bright Side was
created months after the election. Also, even for
channels that were created before the election,
they simply didn’t have much time to gain momentum
and influence the election even if that was their
goal. The reality was that the Soul Publishing
was just putting out a bunch of corny videos
like these. 35 unbelievable cooking hacks. 29
things we do wrong every day. And 5 Minute Crafts
Compilation. To be honest, these videos carried
no real value whatsoever as most of the time the
hacks didn’t even make sense. I mean like what
even is this? The lack of functionality didn’t
really hurt the channels though. They had some
great titles and thumbnails that got people to
click and back in 2017 and 2018, that was really
all you needed. Also, they were posting dozens of
videos every single day so even if 99% of videos
went nowhere, as long as 1% went super viral,
that was all they needed. It didn’t take long for
reaction channels to start clowning on Bright Side
and 5 Minute Crafts but this simply gave them even
more publicity and exposure. Before you knew it,
each of their channels were racking up tens of
millions of subscribers. Bright Side was able to
reach over 30 million subscribers within a matter
of 3 years and 5 Minute Crafts was able to reach
over 60 million subscribers within the same
time period. Also, it wasn’t just YouTube that
they were blowing up on. They also had a massive
presence on Facebook, TikTok, Instagram, Snapchat,
and even Pinterest. By the end of 2019, they were
publishing 1500 videos per month with the help of
550 employees. This was literally the epitome
of a content farm but I mean who could blame
them. They were making millions posting useless
but also harmless content. Unfortunately though,
this hayday didn’t last long as the company’s
first tribulations were just around the corner.
THE ALGORITHM SHIFTS:
The company’s first major challenge came from none
other than YouTube’s infamous algorithm. As we
moved into the 2020s, YouTube started an internal
campaign against clickbait. For obvious reasons,
YouTube was not exactly a fan of clickbait as it
simply gave the entire platform a cheap tabloid
vibe. Not to mention, it likely led to people
spending less time on the platform. This wasn’t
originally a major concern as YouTube’s user base
was simply growing so much. But, as the platform
started to mature, maximizing revenue from current
users became a larger priority than trying to
attract new users. So, YouTube started focusing
on a new metric: average view duration. The longer
people watched your videos, the more likely it
was to be seen by more people. So naturally,
videos that were based around stories and payoffs
started taking off, and we say creators lean
towards longer and longer videos. This, however,
was terrible news for the Soul Publishing.
Virtually all of their content was centered around
a gimmicky hook similar to what we see on TikTok
today. So, once viewers clicked on the video and
saw the hack they came for, they clicked off.
They didn’t care about the other 20 hacks in
the video. This meant that while channels like
Bright Side had a great click through rate, they
had awful viewer retention. As such, the Soul
would decide to change up their content with a new
channel called Actually Happened. Most of you have
probably completely forgotten about this channel
as it has since been deleted so let me remind
about the cringe content they posted. My BF has 74
GFs. I Date Only Psychos. BFF Broke Her Own Leg so
She Can Be The Center Of Attention! Now, these
videos are actually from another channel called
MyStoryAnimated but Actually happened posted the
some sort of stuff. While this is no doubt cringe,
it’s once again effective at getting people to
click. People like hearing about drama and gossip.
Combine this with a storyline and characters and
boom people are more suddenly invested in the
videos than their own financial futures. This
deadly combination of super high click through
rates and ridiculous watch time allowed Actually
Happened to basically blow up overnight but it
wasn’t all sunshines and rainbows. You see, the
channel was so cringe that it was successful at
creating a hate club also over night. People loved
to clown on just how fake their stories were and
honestly you can blame the critics. I think I
remember a video where the kid didn’t want the
dad to drop them off at school because the dad was
gonna drop them off in a helicopter or some crap
like. Yeah, it was really weird. There were also
complaints that the channel was a bad influence as
it sometimes glorified abusive relationships and
cheaters. I mean just listen to this. "I Was Going
To Marry My Gf Until I Met My First Love. I'm A
Cheater". But out of nowhere, the Soul decided
to wipe this channel completely off the face
of the planet as they deleted literally every
single video on the channel. There was never an
official explanation for this but it was probably
just because it got the company too much bad
press. Viewers quickly moved on and forgot about
Acutally Happened but the Soul was back to ground
zero and YouTube was about to evolve even more.
LEFT BEHIND:
As YouTube started focusing
on average view duration, creators naturally
started trying to play this system as well.
They would artificially increase the length of
videos to skew the watch time. They would hide
gift cards throughout the video so that people
would to watch the video over and over again even
if it sucked. Again, this is not what YouTube had
in mind when they started focusing on watch time.
If YouTube really wanted to maximize the time
that people spent on YouTube, they had to focus
on promoting videos that people actually liked
not just videos that people watched longer. So,
YouTube implemented yet another key metric
into the algorithm which is of course viewer
satisfaction. The most blatant implementation of
this is the smiley face surveys but that’s just
1 of likely thousands of variables. For example,
they probably measure how long we watch a video
before getting distracted and scrolling down to
the comments. They probably also measure how our
viewing behavior is different between videos and
who knows what else. The bottomline though is that
what YouTube is looking for are happy viewers
which the Soul doesn’t really have. I mean,
there’s virtually no one that’s actually excited
to watch a new video from Bright Side. At best,
people are looking to burn time. So, I can’t
imagine that the Soul’s viewer satisfaction
metrics are all that great. This wasn’t too big
of an issue back in 2020 when YouTube still had
an emphasis on watch time and the Soul was able to
engineer watch time. But, as YouTube has shifted
more and more towards viewer satisfaction, the
Soul started seeing their viewership drastically
decline. This was also around the time that
short form content started to explode and
everyone was jumping on the band wagon especially
becuase of the pandemic. YouTube launched shorts,
Instagram launched Reels, and TikTok, well TikTok
was TikTok. Much of the demographic that watched
the Soul shifted over to short form content which
makes sense given that it feeds into the same
tendencies. Instant gratification, quick tricks
and tips, and a bunch of dopamine. Not to mention,
with short form content, you usually got
a splash of personality as well as opposed
to some random voice actor working for the
Soul Publishing machine. For obvious reasons,
viewers started ditching the Soul’s channels
in the masses leading us to where we are today.
NO SOUL:
Today, the Soul Publishing isn’t exactly doing
bad as they still have ridiculous followings. 600
million on Facebook, 1.2 billion on YouTube, 90
million on TtikTok, 70 million on Instagram, and
20 million on SnapChat. But with that being said,
the company’s hayday is definitely behind us and
their insane follower counts are starting to mean
less and less. The reality is that their followers
are simply no longer converting into viewers. And
thanks to the YouTube algorithm, this effect will
simply get worse with time. As their newer videos
get fewer views, YouTube will promote their future
videos even less which will simply make it even
harder to get views. So, it definitely seems like
it’s just a matter of time until this content farm
or propaganda machine or whatever it is becomes a
blip in internet history and that’s the story
of the 1.2 billion sub YouTuber that’s losing
it all. Someone else that’s at risk of losing
it all is short form platforms. If you’d like
to see why companies are already giving up
on short form content, check out this video.